- At a time when we're
constantly being told
that this time is unlike any other
it's critical that we confront
our past and systemic racism
and see its echos in
our present challenges.
Only then will we be able
to overcome our divisions
and build a more just
and inclusive society.
Mitch Landrieu has shown
us what needs to be done.
Now it's up to us to make sure we do it.
As we look around our country
we do see citizen activism
on the rise and a new
generation that's speaking out,
running for office and
entering public service.
I'm proud that they can look
to this award and be inspired
by Mayor Landrieu and those
who have come before him.
And I hope that politics
will once again be seen
as my father saw it as a noble profession.